eux les cherry est ce que vous avez vu
cette histoire un roland garros alors
moi je pose à casser la plus grande
joueuse du moment où on va pas se mentir
c'est la numéro deux mondiale mais elle
est numéro un dans le parce que c'est
elle qui a gagné le dernier tournoi du
grand chelem c'est vraiment c'est la
meilleure joueuse du moment la japonaise
et elle a déclaré forfait
c'est la grande favorite du tournoi dé
passer par l'app colis polémique qu'elle
a initiée en décidant de boycotter les
médias c'est une décision lourde mais
qui vise à préserver sa santé mentale
comme l a annoncé sur les réseaux
sociaux
je vous dire ce qui s'est passé en fait
c'est qu'elle n'a pas été en conférence
de presse après sa victoire en premier
tour elle a eu quinze mille euros
d'amendé l'a dit j'ai pas envie d'y
aller mais je vais vous dire moi je
trouve ça fou qu'elle prenne une amende
elles ce sont là pour jouer au tennis
s'ils ont pas envie de parler à la
presse
ils font ce qu'ils veulent c'est me
désole et gilles verdez va dire non mais
écoute moi bien je vais ouvrir les
vannes a omis osaka elle est numéro deux
mondial moi je peux te dire maintenant
si nadal il fait la même chose je peux
te dire tu vas voir quand il est dans la
merde et nelly l'escroc marafih les
moutons d'aller parler à la pression ne
te parler à toi non mais ce rigoler et
ce qu'il a dit d'ailleurs nadal il dit à
lire entre les lignes je ne ferai pas ça
parce que c'est un grand mais pourquoi
pas du tout mais cyril de fer et la
williams à elle a défendu et je serai
l'année cc c'est la presse qui l'a fait
star c'est pas la presse qui choisit les
pas de bitume et si elle est championne
de tennis justine
s'il ya bien un truc où t'as pas besoin
de la presse ces championnes de tennis
qu'est ce que t'en à [ __ ] tu es là
qu'elle vient de gagner à toi du gros
chêne je crois qu'elle est parlée à aa3
gars qu'est ce qu'elle en la sauce que
si vous la série sauf que elle paraît un
petit peu enfant gâté parce qu'elle
n'est pas mal malmené par la presse et
bien alors ceci s'explique elle expliqué
est là elle a envoyé une lettre à mon
avis au lieu de dire d'abord sur les
réseaux sociaux elle aurait dû d'abord
le dire aux gens de la fédé en
expliquant pour quelle raison elle noire
n'est pas donc ça c'était nous le
cheminement voilà après elle expliqué
voilà j'ai fait une dépression
ah oui de maintenance avec piqué pour
moi lardy l'a dit parce qu'elle s'est
rendue compte qu'elle son geste n'était
pas compris elle aurait dû d'abord
expliqué et après moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi mais je
suis plus fan d'elle et je vais vous
dire ce qui se passe c'est que là il ya
une levée de boucliers c'est que ya là
encore plus de fans je crois qu'à la fin
mais médiatique énorme ici nam erreur il
le veut
mais attendez c'est un exercice qui l'a
stress qu'est ce qu'on attend d'elle
qu'elle arrive championnat tennis syrie
partiel se sont stressées elles disent à
lui que ça lui prend la tête quand il
sort ses programmes télé normale à
stress est là pour jouer au tennis et
gagner alors je trouve scandaleux c'est
de mettre une amende de 15000 au hameau
si ces secondes à l'aise et les
scandaleux et déplacés on va dire qu on
n a pas envie de parler après le match
elle a pas envie elle est payée c'est
une rebelle de pacotille elle a des bons
joueurs ont joué à vienne championne
mais c'est valable pour moi et pour nous
d'attirer les grands chelems elle est
payée mais qu'est ce que vous racontez à
l'aiguillé pour faire des grands chelems
mais c'est la deuxième fois elle est
payée matin quoi c'est normal et signé
par l'espagne et la grèce c'est la
presse qui n'a pas aidé à démêler la
presse pardon dans les conférences de
presse qui sont quand même emblématique
de tous les grands chelems il a fait
partie du décor au duel bien faire et on
a dû signaler que mon père emmène en
voyage vraiment eia alors à moins de
francfort ce n'était pas la présence
mais bien vous dire que naquit et nec
sont pas très contents qu'ils évaluaient
la cinor jean claude perez compte en
banque selon patrick donc à naomi osaka
lambert tout le monde elle est numéro un
mondial
c'est la personne qui vous plaît vous
allez voir s'il y en a omis osaka denis
je fais pas wimbledon je vais pas lui a
sauvé aig jeu plus aucun tournoi
vous allez voir s'ils vont rigoler
qu'elle a deux gros truc en plus d'elle
pardon mais je trouve que pour une
championne à ce niveau je trouve qu'être
dépressive c'est pas bien y compris pour
elle parce que ça veut dire que le monde
file feu lâchait tout si vous êtes un
crevard vous êtes un clébard
[Applaudissements]
comment de cheryl a raison elle inventa
la selle elle a gagné plusieurs
dimanches championnat red sinon il me
regarde ce soir s'il vous plaît si naomi
me regarde ce soir je suis à fond avec
toi mais là au mit et je vais d'ailleurs
le maître sur les réseaux sociaux
si les j'espère que tu me suivra sur les
réseaux non moi je te kiffe voilà si tu
veux faire quelques balles avec moi je
ne poserai aucune qui s'ajoute à aucune
question
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] il est avec moi
ont faim qui vous plaise ou pas par les
théories mais le tennis féminin en
marche avec les droits télé donc aller
les conférences y trouvait pas comme ça
mais lienhard vertement la télé les
journées six mois
[Rires]
on allait bien
terry ne touchera série allait bien
content quand les gens et
l'applaudissent je vous en fais toutes
les compétitions
wimbledon est tout ce que vous avez
évoqué elle va jouer chez sa mère dire
la vérité je vous calmer tout de suite
mais non et là je vais je pense que je
connais un petit peu mieux le tennis
comme le glc une truffe et je me sers
aussi bien c'est bien parce que je n'ai
pas joué comme je n'y connais rien au
team bataille bat si je voulais me sylla
il vous trompez cir est une truffe êtes
toutes et tous au tennis vous êtes
détriment des placements sûrs terme
aller mais je veux pas parler avec des
chefs mais je ne peux pas la tennis avec
tout ça chez dargaud est mis à nous et à
chercher sous la jambière
je vous dire un truc non mais on a cassé
la seule maintenant et unique star du
tennis mondial
il ya serena williams qui va bientôt
prendre sa retraite on espère le plus
tard possible parce que c'est vrai qu'on
l'adoré aussi c'est la plus grande star
je peux vous dire les les tournois ils
vont aller la chercher quoi qu'il arrive
et yvon et ibos baissée devant elles et
ils vont fermer leur gueule parce que je
vous dirais osaka déjà qui part de
roland garros pour le tournoi féminin
c'est une catastrophe
giuly c'est une catastrophe sur stade 2
on se fait une cape à l'original femme
pouvait gagner le sud cerezo osaka ça ne
la connaît dans la rue mais aux accords
les tms ne sont pas une truffe au tennis
il a joué le dire que vous faites un
micro trottoir à la raison
j'ai déjà dit ça va nous aider connu pas
au japon merci mais je me suis dit
raisonnement si je vous suis dans votre
raisonnement donc je ne veux pas qu'elle
fasse aucune interview de toute sa vie
de joueur de tennis est le faire que des
installations face cadeaux contrôle et
sert à les insérer le cnir signale et
tout le monde fermera la porte
voilà et géraldine maillet quand vous
gagnera un match de tennis n'était pas
le fils alors mairie dans un instant je
suis nullement dans là quand on parle de
nomi odac a commencé les normes c'est
comme je vous dis c'est comme ma soeur
ça fait partie de son métier ça nous on
vous dit pas faire les conférences de
presse epa
[Applaudissements]